We are the last best hope of the world and
we're in the very, very unfortunate period
of turning our back on first principles.
The government is at the point of becoming
an unlimited government.
It is a crisis unlike any one that is previously
met.
Any political renewal in the United States
will start from the Declaration and the Constitution.
We have our natural inherent rights from God.
The explicit purpose of government is to preserve
those rights.
Governments are instituted among men to secure
their rights, not give us rights.
Hillsdale was founded in 1844 on the western
frontier with a charter that says, "We'll
take our student body without regard to race,
sex or national origin."
When the Civil War broke out, every male student
left Hillsdale to enlist.
The Carter Administration said, "We get to
regulate you comprehensively."
The heavy hand of liberalism would have been
brought to bear on education at Hillsdale.
And we got rid of the money, so now there's
no indirect money from the government coming
into the college.
And to Hillsdale's credit, it did not concede
an inch on that.
What do we want the college to be like in
ten years?
What is now an exciting on-campus phenomenon
will be recognized nationwide.
It was academic in the best sense.
It sort of attempted to take one back to first
principles and to state them cogently, so
that one could follow the argument.
Could you tell me a bit about your graduate
school statesmanship?
It gives a degree in the grade books that
are necessary to understand the American Revolution
and politics.
They keep saying all we need is more regulation.
It seems like the government's-
It's in the belly of the beast.
Speaking truth to power.
Hello and welcome to Constitution 201, Hillsdale's
online course on the Constitution.
Their first Constitution course ... 200,000
people signed up to listen to the great scholars
of Hillsdale.
Each one of these bubbles is full of the gas
methane.
And it sounds odd to say that this little
college in this little corner of southeastern
Michigan can lead a renewal, but it can.
Hillsdale is producing a generation of missionaries
for liberty.
A small, [inaudible 00:02:43] minority that
will radiate through the whole Republic.
That is what our purpose is here, to become
men and women of character who make a difference
in this country.
We are going to have to have a revival of
the principles of human freedom, and because
our college has never forgotten those principles,
never abandoned that task, we're going to
help provide that spark.